you know i want to talk about something  kind of upbeat recently fans were abuzz  after the news that the much anticipated  snyder cut of justice league  would feature batman saying the f word  did you hear about this  yeah i mean i haven't heard about  virtually anything else  yeah it's all anybody's talking about  batman's saying the f word  but you know i just want to say one  thing if it's anything like the snyder  cut of batman versus superman  well it might be disappointing take a  look  you don't understand there's no time  i understand  wow what the [ __ ] so mean  i don't even have any [ __ ]  superpowers like you  i just got into crime fighting because i  witnessed my parents  i [ __ ] hate my life i [ __ ] hate  being batman